we are on number 11
number 11.
sinai customized her bicycle by
exchanging the front wheel for a wheel
that had one half the diameter
of the back wheel
so this will be a weird looking bicycle
you have a small wheel in front
and then see if i can draw a bicycle
oh it looks like something you know and
you have a huge wheel in the back right
because the diameter of this wheel is
half of the diameter of that wheel
now when sinai rides the bicycle how
many revolutions does the front wheel
make for each revolution of the back
wheel all right well when you do this
when you do this problem what you need
it so the front how many references does
the front wheel make for each revolution
the back wheel and let me just make sure
it says that the front wheel
has
half the diameter of the back wheel
so let me ask you a question if if the
back wheel goes around well that's
essentially what they're just asking
let's let's make up numbers let's say
that the back wheels
um
the back wheels diameter or let's say
it's circumf it's radius
right let's say the back wheel has a
radius of 2.
so then what's its circumference its
circumference for the back wheel would
be 2 pi r so it would be
2 times pi times 2 which is equal to 4
pi
right
the circumference if this
has half the diameters it'll also have
half the radius so the circumference
would just be 2 pi r which would be 2 pi
so this one if you have half the
diameter you also have half the
circumference
and so
when
this wheel does one revolution
when this wheel does one revolution
how far has the bicycle traveled
assuming in you know the wheel hasn't
skidded or anything
well when this back wheel does one
revolution the bicycle would have
traveled four pi
whatever our units you know four pi
feet
if that's our units right
so if the bicycles travel the four pi
units it's gonna you know it's gonna
travel four five units in the front of
the bicycle as well so the if if we've
traveled four pi units how many times
does this wheel have to turn around to
travel four pi units well in one
revolution
this wheel it's two pi
so this wheel actually has to turn
around twice
it turns around twice for every one
revolution of the big wheel
hopefully that makes sense you just
realize that one revolution of the big
wheel is going to be twice the
circumference of the front wheel and so
the front wheel has to turn around twice
when the byte goes over that same
distance
so the answer so the question is how
many revolutions does the front wheel
make for each revolution of the back
wheel well the answer is c
that looks like an e but the answer is c
2. problem number 12.
all right
a list of numbers contains p positive
and n negative numbers so p paws
n negative
if a number is picked at random from the
list the probability
that the number is positive is
three-fifths
what is the value of n over
p
okay so the probability
of getting a positive
is n
is no no sorry is three
so what is the probability of getting a
positive a probability of getting a
positive is going to be equal to p
over
over n or is it going to be it's the
probability of of the the number of
positive numbers we have over the total
numbers we have right that's the
probability of getting a positive number
right if this was red marbles and blue
marbles the probability of getting a red
marble would be you know the number of
red over the total number of marbles
right so similar here it's the
probability it's the number of positive
numbers over the total numbers and the
total numbers are the positive numbers
plus
the negative numbers
and now they are asking us for what is
the value
well again i just want to make sure i'm
doing it right if the number is picked
at random from the list the probability
that the number is positive right this
is the probability that's positive it's
3 over 5. what is the value of n over p
so now solve for n over p
so we could cross multiply here right so
we could say 5
p
5 p is equal to 3 times this
is equal to
3 p
plus 3 n i just cross multiply
and then let's see subtract p from both
sides you get 2 p is equal to 3
n
and we want to figure out n over p right
so let's divide both sides by p so you
get 2 is equal to 3
n over p and let's divide both sides by
3 and you get 2 over 3 is equal to n
over p and we are done
n over p
is equal to 2 over 3 which is choice c
wasn't too bad
problem 13.
clear image invert colors and i will do
it in this tacky green
problem 13.
the total daily cost c in dollars
of producing x units of a certain
product is given by the function all
right we got a
cost function right here c of x is equal
to
x
minus 200
over x
plus k
and they're telling us k is a constant
and x is less than or equal to 100 x is
less than or equal to 100.
fair enough if 20 units were produced
yesterday for a total cost
of 640 dollars what is the value of k so
20 units so they're essentially saying
that
c
of 20 the cost of producing 20 units is
equal to
640 dollars
so we can just use this information to
now solve for k so c of 20
so c
of 20 is going to be equal put in 20
into this equation so it's
times 20
minus 200
all of that over 20 right c of 20 right
all of it over 20. and we also know that
oh sorry plus k i can't forget the plus
k plus k
is equal to and we know that equals to
right
and what is this equal to
well we actually don't even have to
multiply it right because this is 600
times 20 and what's 200 200 is
10 times 20
right so you can divide the top and the
bottom by 20 so you get 20 20 20. so
you're just left with
600 and you could multiply it out if you
don't understand what i just did
but you get 600
minus
plus k is equal to 640.
so you get 590
plus k is equal to 640. subtract 590
from both sides you get k is equal to
50. and that is choice
b
so you literally just have to
set you know figure out
substitute the x in when you know into
our cost function
and then set that equal to 640 and you
solve for k
problem 14
14.
for how many ordered pairs of positive
integers x y
positive integers integers x y
is two x
plus three y
less than
six so these are positive integers right
so let's i mean we could figure them out
zero we can't use zero so if x is
x
y
if x is
one
right what can y equal so then we have 2
then we have 2 plus 3y is less than 6.
this is the case of x is equal to 1. so
then we'd have 3y is less than 4. so the
only so you know we'd have y would have
to be less than four thirds so the only
situation where y is less than four
thirds is y would have to be one right
because that's the only positive integer
less than four thirds if x is two
then we have four plus 3y right 2 times
2 is less than 6.
and so you have
3y
is less than 2 y is less than 2 thirds
well i don't see any any value where
i don't see any positive integers that
are less than two-thirds so
x can't even be equal to two right
so neither of these numbers can get any
bigger than one or one so there's only
one ordered pair of positive integers
that
positive integers and that's the trick
that satisfied this equation 1 and 1.
and we know because immediately when we
just raise one of them above 2 we get
above 6. no matter what we can't find a
positive integer that satisfies it so
that's it it's just choice a not too bad
and i will see you in the next video